we have to talk about what is going on
in the state of georgia
and i know that there are people who
aren't going to like this conversation
republicans in georgia are going to vote
for a man
who can barely speak and is unable to
explain a single policy
this is a man who can barely put
together a coherent sentence and
unfortunately because of some of the
circumstances
it's almost like the elephant in the
room that cannot be discussed now i'm
talking about former professional
football player herschel walker
herschel walker is running for senate in
georgia against the incumbent democratic
senator rafael warnock and walker
doesn't make any sense when he speaks he
seems unable to speak and unable to
think
and when you talk about it republicans
act all offended and they play the games
where they claim it's actually what the
left does they say that's racist
or you're stigmatizing mental illness
or you're being racist against ebonics
or whatever
now we're gonna go through these claims
one by one and we have a new example of
herschel walker just making no sense now
i'm going to admit to you
i don't know
why walker can't speak
he played football there's speculation
that there is a brain injury that might
be at play but when you bring up the
brain injury part there are people who
say david it's not a brain injury it's
mental illness herschel walker has
talked about dissociative identity
disorder and then they will say if you
talk about a brain injury from football
you're ignoring the plight of mental
illness but at the same time mental
illness doesn't actually explain being
unable to speak or explain one policy
position ever
and then some people will show up and
say david that's racism you are
essentially just criticizing herschel
walker for speaking ebonics that's
racist but that's not it at all that's
not what's going on and ebonics doesn't
prevent you from answering a question it
it
it's crazy
that the right who says oh all the
leftists they get all offended
now they're playing the i'm offended
game when we go hey guys herschel walker
can't explain a single thing that he
believes
the issue here really is republican
voters
seem willing to vote for someone to
avoid voting for a democrat who cannot
explain his opinion on any issue now
here's the latest example herschel
walker did one of these events in some
kind of bar restaurant who knows on fox
news brian kilmeade uh interviewed him
and said hey
why aren't you going to debate or why
aren't you debating your opponent rafael
warnock
and herschel walker just he can't
explain it it doesn't make any sense
senator raphael warnock wants to debate
you you didn't debate during the
primaries where you walked away with 68
percent of the republican votes
why would you commit to a debate well
first of all senator warnock has nothing
else to talk about he don't want to talk
about the high gas prices he don't want
to talk about the high groceries i've
told him many times i'm ready to debate
him anytime any day i just want to make
it for the fans not about a political
party or about some media and all
they're doing is talking i want to make
it a fair and equitable debate
are you worried about the moderator what
understand he's saying
he warnock doesn't have anything to talk
about
and i'm willing to debate if it's for
the fans
that that's not an answer
that that should immediately make us say
can he think because he's not saying
anything that makes sense
and there's other examples that we've
covered as well this one was when cnn
reporter manu raju
asked
hershel walker should there be new gun
laws after the texas shooting and he
says what i like to do is see it and
everything and stuff
with cnn
are you do you support any new gun laws
in the wake of this texas shooting
do you support the new gun laws in the
wake of what i like to do what i like
doing
and uh and everything and stuff i like
to see it you know
my favorite new jersey channel he likes
to see it and everything and stuff and
then the last example of this uh he
appeared like the following day or the
day after that on fox news and he was
asked about his solution to school
shootings and it was a department that
can look at young men looking at women
looking at social media see that is the
person willing that weapon you know kane
kia able you know and uh you know that's
the problem that we have and i said what
we need to do is look into how we can
stop those things you know he talked
about doing a disinformation what about
getting a department that can look at
young men that's looking at uh women
that looking at uh just social media
what about doing that looking into
things like that and we can stop that
that way but okay
this doesn't make any sense and the
really you know we're being hard on
herschel walker
because he doesn't make any sense but
the republicans in georgia are so
determined and desperate that rafael
warnock is bad
that they don't even mention that walker
doesn't actually say anything he seems
unable to actually put together a
coherent opinion about any particular
issue when it's joe biden
it's biden dementia
and biden stuttered
and so on and so forth and then herschel
walker has not been able to explain a
single policy position the entire
campaign
refused to debate in the primary so far
is refusing to debate in the general
election and they don't say a word about
it it is number one obviously an
incredible double standard but number
two
it says a lot about the modern
republican party
in georgia right now
that it doesn't even seem to phase them
like if i said to you
what is walker's plan to lower the gas
prices that he has identified as a
problem it's not that you might not know
it's that he has not explained it once
in any way that makes any sense
if i ask you well what is herschel
walker's plan on inflation or to create
jobs
you can look at the things that he has
said words have come out of his mouth i
mean there are letters which assemble
words that i generally speaking
recognize there is not an actual
position on anything and republicans if
you if you try to bring it up they go oh
you're either making fun of brain
injuries or mental illness or you're
you're racist this is exactly what they
accuse the left of doing
and now they themselves are doing it
it's wild out there folks it is wild we
will have these clips on our instagram
you can find us at davidpakmanshow on
instagram you can find me on instagram
at
david.pacman we will take a quick break
and be right back
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
us is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below